[Music]
you've come a long way to compete in the
great discipline league
and prove yourself a discipline master
now that you've made it to the finals
you're up against some tough competition
as you enter the arena the referee
explains the rules
there are three diskey disks you can use
disk a will always summon
a level 3 burger sore disc b
summons a churrozard that has a 56
chance of being level two a 22 percent
chance
of being level four and a 22 chance of
being level
six disc c will summon a level five
juar tortilla 49 of the time
and a level one bar tortilla 51 percent
of the time
all discipline fully heal between
battles
and the higher level discipline always
wins
no matter what type it is in round one
you'll face a single opponent and get to
choose your disc
before she picks from the remaining two
which one
gives you the best chance of winning
before you start calculating
probabilities take a look at the disks
themselves
discs b and c each have a more than 50
percent
chance of summoning a level 2 or a level
discipline respectively this means that
disc
a's guaranteed level 3 burger soar
will always have better than even odds
of winning
if you choose b or c your opponent could
pick
a and gain an advantage over you and
c fares worst of all being more than
fifty percent
likely to lose to any opponent
so you choose a hoping for the best and
sure enough
your level three burgers or triumphs
over the level two
churros are now it's time for round two
and while you've prepared for trouble
you didn't anticipate they'd make it
double
you get to choose any one of the three
discs again
but this time you'll be in a battle
royale
against two opponents each using one of
the other discs
whoever summons the highest level
discipline wins
should you stick with a or switch
for many discipline trainers it seems
intuitive that if a
is the best at beating b or c it should
also be the best at beating
b and c strangely enough
that couldn't be further from the truth
let's calculate the odds
for a to win b has to summon a level 2
discipline and c has to summon a level
1.
those are independent events so their
odds are 56
times 51 or 29
for disc b a level 2 churrozard would
automatically lose to the burger sore
but you'd have two ways to win the 22
chance of summoning a level 6 would give
you an outright win
while a level 4 could still win if
c summons a level 1. adding up those
mutually exclusive possibilities
gives you odds of about 33 percent
finally c will win with a level 5 war
tortilla
as long as b doesn't summon its level 6
giving c a 38 chance overall
so while disk a's middling consistency
was an advantage in a single match-up
multiple fights increase the odds that
one of the
other discs will summon something better
and although
c was the worst first round option its
decent chance of summoning a strong
level 5
gives it an advantage when facing two
opponents simultaneously
this sort of counter-intuitive result is
why misleading statistics
are a favored tool of unscrupulous
politicians
and nefarious discipline trainers alike
fortunately your war tortilla comes out
level 5
and makes short work of its foes you're
about to celebrate
when your rivals capture the referee and
announce
a surprise third round you'll have to
repeat
each of the previous matches in
succession with all the same rules
except for one you must keep the same
disc
throughout which should you choose to
give yourself the best chance
at becoming that which no one ever was
[Applause]
nobody becomes the very best without
practice
if you're looking for a way to make
problem-solving practice fun
try out brilliant brilliance many stem
courses take a hands-on approach to
learning
by featuring interactive challenges in
their math library
you can tackle probability fundamentals
or study subjects like
algebra geometry and calculus from
beginning to end
visit brilliant.org slash ted ed to try
it out
and the first 833 of you to use that
link
will receive 20 off the annual premium
subscription fee